My name is Shakil. I'm a student at
Dumin
at Bandung Barat. I want to ask about
uh Dr. Zak, you often explain that Islam
teach universal brotherhood where all
human beings are brothers no matter
their country or school.
But in many Muslim communities,
including in my country, Indonesia,
there's still a lot of division and
centuries fanaticis.
Uh sometimes even worse than how people
treat non-Muslim. In your opinion, how
can Muslims truly achieve universal
brotherhood if we are still divide among
ourselves?
Thank you.
>> The sisters ask important question.
She's saying that in her country
Indonesia
even Muslims fight among themselves
and that is common in other countries
also not only Indonesia and there are
various divisions various sects various
groups. What is the solution? The
solution for unity amongst the Muslims.
Allah says in the Quran in surah Iran
chapter number three verse number 103,
hold strongly to the rope of Allah and
be not divided. Hold strongly to the
rope of Allah and be not divided. That
means we Muslims should be united on the
basis of the Quran. The rope of Allah is
the glorious Quran and say hadith. So
the only way the Muslim ummah can be
united is on the basis of the Quran.
Unfortunately
we follow other things than the Quran.
Maybe you may follow culture, no
problem. But if it goes against the
Quran, the Quran is more superior. So
the only way the Muslim um can be united
is on the basis of the Quran. And Allah
also says in several places in the Quran
Obey Allah and obey the messenger. In
Surah Imran chapter number 3 verse
number 32. In surah Iran chapter 3 verse
number 132. In surah na ch 5 verse
number 59. In surah maida ch 5 verse
number 92. In surah fap verse number 1.
In surah fap 8 verse number 20. In surah
faj chap 8 verse number 46 in surah ch4
verse number 54. In surah ch4 verse
number 56 in surah mjadela chapter 58
verse number 13 in surah tabun chapter
64 verse number 12. several places
obey Allah and obey the messenger. So if
we have this why do we differ
give the proof from the Quran. So if we
concentrate on the Quran,
anyone says Islam says
produce your proof in truthful. So we
rather than talking about the Quran, you
say so much so say so and so thing this.
If theust gives you reference of Quran,
you follow the if it doesn't give then
keep it aside. Correct? If Dr. Zak says
it is nothing in the Quran, Dr. Zak is
zero in Islam. If I quote the Quran, you
follow. If I quote the say hadith you
follow. So if we stick to the Quran and
say hadith the Muslim um will be united
and we should not be divided over small
issues. We should be united on the basis
of Quran. So if we study the Quran and
we implement the Quran and we stick to
it inshallah we'll be united.
Hope that answers the question.